et de nombreux invités se sont relayés
toute la journée sur notre antenne pour
commenter cette actualité parmi eux
pierre et of reporter écrivain et
riccardo bocco spécialiste du
moyen-orient
en revanche il s'agit de il s'agirait du
débordement avec un soutien à une
organisation terroriste organisations
terroristes palestiniennes
il ramasse qui nous arrose le rocket
depuis lundi ont des requêtes qui sont
relie sentait la ville est sur toutes
les villes israéliennes
ce ne sont pas des feux d'artifice il ya
des blessés il ya des morts il ya des
habitations détruites par le biais trois
jours on a été réveillés quatre fois
pendant la nuit avec des explosions et
des sirènes
on est dans une situation où pour sortir
de l'impasse
il faudrait imposer à l'état il ya de
renoncer à une série de politiques comme
celle de la colonisation pour commencer
pour ne pas parler de la nécessité à
moyen terme de évacuer les colonies pour
laisser la place à la population
palestinienne d'évoluer sur différents
plans y compris les plats nationaux
social et culturel mais également
économique parce que l'économie
palestinienne est pratiquement otage de
l'économie israélienne
effectivement il ya des enfants
palestiniens qui sont morts et c'est
très regrettable
il faut savoir qu ils sont conservés
comme bouclier humain en or hamas il
faut savoir que 20 % 20 % des requêtes
du ramasse ont relié sur israël ils ont
relié 2002 puis depuis lundi 20 % tombe
à l'intérieur de gaza sont des dégâts
tue des enfants et tu certainement plus
en tant que l'usraël non tu pour la
simple raison qu il serait très bien
avant chaque frappe aérienne tant qu'il
n'y aura pas un point sur la table qui
dise stop à la colonisation pour
commencer ce temps pas différent autre
chose israël continuera mais ce qui est
dramatique dans tout ça c'est pas
simplement une question de soutien aux
palestiniens
c'est que on voit la société israélienne
s'enfoncer dans
en année dans le cancer de la
colonisation